donc là j'ai un client qui m'a apporté
un bain un génois le génois c'est la
plus grande voile qui assure un bateau à
près de 200 kilomètres des côtes
normandes valérie vial garde un oeil sur
l'anr dans son atelier à coignières
cette maître voilier travail est réparé
tous les types de voile depuis quelques
années on voit apparaître des voiles en
carbone dévoile enfin tex et des laminés
donc là ça se casse beaucoup plus
facilement et là on les répare beaucoup
beaucoup plus il ya des files qui sont
particulier si les fibres avec un petit
peu de paraffine dessus c'est à dire que
quand on coud lui chauffe ça fait faire
fondre la paraffine et ça bouge tous les
trous ce flacon et qu'une voilà les
étangs que valérie vial comment sa
formation à 17 ans dans une voilerie à
ouistreham en normandie
elle débarque ensuite à saint quentin en
yvelines j'ai commencé à arriver ici
j'ai travaillé pour nos de voilerie qui
est à saint cyr l'école et puis après
j'ai travaillé pour la base de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines pendant 18
ans en tant que maître voilier j'ai créé
mon post sur la base de loisirs et puis
maintenant ça fait sept ans que j'ai
créé ma propre entreprise en région
parisienne comme ya beaucoup de gens qui
naviguent que ce soit en planche à voile
ou en kitesurf ou en bateau ça navigue
quand même pas mal donc j'ai un petit
peu de clients c'est régulier 32 ans
d'activités pour cette normande de coeur
et les voiles n'ont quasiment plus de
secret pour elle elle passe tout entre
ses mains comme le spi le génois ou
encore la grande voile sa machine à
coudre pour acolytes valérie développe
au fil des ans un côté artistique
j'étais beaucoup plus créatrices que
couturière donc du coup j'ai toujours
créé plein de choses toujours des sacs
donc je recycle est énormément les
voiles de bateau tout ce que je pouvais
recycle et se recycle et en pochette en
sac en pouffant table son imagination
débordante et éco-responsable l'amène à
créer plusieurs objets originaux
réalisés exclusivement à partir de
voiles recyclées donc ça peut être des
voiles de très vieilles c'est-à-dire
qu'elles volent au début elle était en
coton donc comme celle ci c'est une
voile qui vient de delisle de loctudy
qui en rouge parce qu'on faisait
beaucoup de rouge à l'époque et du tan
tan c'est le marron foncé autrement
voilà notre 6 rec je récupère même les
vieilles râle un ghetto je dessine
d'abord mon sac et puis après 20 par
rapport à la voile il faut regarder si
la voile est encore bonne donc on la met
à laver dans la machine à laver et puis
on voit ceux qui restent et puis après
on coupe ses morceaux en fonction de ce
qu'on veut comme modèle tout simplement
après vous avez tous qui planche à voile
alors c'est des couleurs un peu flashy
parce que les années 70 80 c'était que
des couleurs qu'on voit bien sur l'eau
de très très loin la confection d'un
accessoire représente pas loin de 20
heures de travail pour valérie qui en
vrai passionné n'a de cesse d'innover sa
spécialité le vent peut souffler fort
sur coignières les voiles sont
accessibles à tous